[Music]
hey everyone today we're going to
discuss the best hulk smash and fight
moment in all his marvel movie
appearances if you liked the video be
sure to leave us a like and subscribe to
the channel to not miss out on any
future content regarding your favorite
movies without further ado let's get
started
despite being a horrible movie there is
a seriously cool scene in 2003's hulk in
which eric bana's edition of the unique
character knocks down a bunch of tanks
it takes place when he's on the run and
sam elliott's general ross deploys the
armed services to undertake him the hulk
tosses one tank into the air tears the
roof off yet another and utilizes it to
smash down what's left of it he deforms
another tank's big gun so that it points
at the driver of the vehicle the scene
was the perfect representation of the
hulk's power and influence in the entire
movie the flinging of the very first
tank in general and especially
emphasized hulk's invulnerability as he
simply took a shell that was being shot
at him just like an everyday person
would have taken being struck by a
ping-pong ball hence setting the tone
for his future endeavors
in his soul standalone movie the first
embodiment of the incredible hulk in the
mcu is primarily invincible attempting
to prove more than a contest for
soldiers and high-tech weapon systems
nevertheless after being offered the
cybernetically enhanced therapies and
then being infused with bruce banner's
gamma-irradiated plasma a notably
power-obsessed warrior named emil
blonsky strives to become as mighty as
hulk and the outcome is abomination we
were all enthusiastic when we discovered
that the abomination would be making an
appearance against hulk in 2008 the
incredible hulk but we were obviously
annoyed after we saw him instead of the
bright green scaly skin the abomination
here has the appearance of a dark corn
dog to make matters worse he completely
lacks the legendary ears irrespective he
was an abomination in terms of
resilience and fighting capabilities in
the film's climactic scene the two super
strong monsters battled on the streets
of new york so it was a very
catastrophic event abomination who was
considerably larger and spinier than
hulk is a cleverer and more brutal
fighter than hulk throughout most of
their fight but hulk ends up winning and
he gets a few hard shots in just before
his triumph when abomination was on the
ground and hulk repeatedly punched his
face into the pavement there was a
particularly impressive hulk smash
occasion even though abomination was
consequently repeating his dialogue is
that all you've got the damage and
destruction were so genuine that you can
feel the pain and anguish of each
pulverized construction brick at the
scene
hulk and thor of course mates after
having to fight together during the
battle of new york and the battle of
sokovia and they ultimately team up in
thor ragnarok but their primary
relationship had a bumpy start on the
shield helicarrier a blast provoked by
one of hawkeye's crossbow bolts to stir
bruce banner to the point where he
failed to keep control and converted
into the hulk hulk battered and bruised
thor's nose and garnered a shot from
mjolnir to the head during their
struggle but the tussle was brought to
an end when a fighter plane distracted
hulk causing him to strike it and drop
to the ground the finest hulk smash
occasion of course came much later when
hulk pretty much ended their previous
tussle by jabbing thor off screen
during the first three quarters of the
avengers the hulk was pretty ineffective
this could not be aided he was a
disaster waiting to happen and it's
uncertain why nick fury would want him
when he was responsible for destroying
the whole shield helicarrier it's not
until the final confrontation that the
hulk managed to prove his significance
especially against the chitauri invading
forces bruce banner who was last seen
fighting thor on the shield helicarrier
came to help his fellow avengers battle
loki's alien armed force which included
shitari security forces chitari on-air
vehicles and giant chitari leviathans
when tony stark decided to draw one of
the leviathans towards the avengers with
the corresponding statement i'm bringing
the party to you captain america best
advised bruce banner that it was a great
time to get angry he disclosed that he
was always angry and like a real
superhero banner instantaneously
converted into the hulk and brutally
murdered the ginormous monster with a
solitary powerful strike
loki the god of mischief like ultron is
not frightened of many beings including
thor and his foster father odin
admittedly he is a god and among the
most potent as guardians nevertheless
until loki could populate his head with
feelings of supremacy and almost
overcome earth the hulk decided to
intervene to disintegrate his illusion
of progress during the battle of new
york hulk managed to track down loki at
the upper edge of stark tower where he
was controlling the fight and charged at
him loki was having none of that and
attempted to speak hulk down by
declaring himself to be a god and trying
to tell him that he would never be
harassed by him the god of mischief's
first authentic and physiological taste
of embarrassment and thwart came when he
was picked up by the legs and smacked
him repetitively on the ground like a
rubber ball it was painful enough to
seriously harm him hulk then decided to
walk away like a complete macho man
saying the legendary words puny god
the opening up of avengers age of ultron
saw the protagonist champions ransacking
a hydra framework that was inhabited by
baron wolfgang von strucker the villain
deployed forces to defend the platform
each carrying weapons which were powered
by the infinity stones the avengers were
rather potent for them every player on
the team had their time in the limelight
with hulk shattering his adversaries
left right and middle nevertheless his
fondly remembered hulk's magician in
this incident took place when most of
the bad dudes struck the avengers from
the inside of a bunker when black widow
asked does anyone want to deal with that
bunker the hulk showed up from nowhere
and went straight through it shattering
it into tiny pieces
the harsh reality is that the hulk was
whacked in the shins during the battle
against iron man's hulkbuster armor aka
veronica but he tried to smash on his
own during what was an utterly
incredible back and forth struggle we
never really developed a sense of how
much harm the hulk can do until we saw
him go bonkers in avengers age of ultron
after being entranced by the scarlet
witch the hulk went on a killing spree
in an african city demolishing
everything and possibly wounding
innocent civilians he was pretty much
unstoppable until tony stark stepped in
to help with his hulkbuster body armor
to alleviate the risk of collateral
damage even with the most cutting edge
available technology stark would not
have been able to handle or beat the
hulk the hulk strikes were so potent
that star got to convene additional body
armor components during the battle
especially when hulk was using a large
yellow metal pole to pierce the armor
plating from behind the pair of them
attempted to level quite a few
structures notwithstanding stark's best
attempts to curtail the destruction the
showdown was utterly devastating with
big punches innocence and threat and the
destruction of infrastructure despite
his anger and frustration hulk had a
sense of morality almost all of the time
but this battle illustrated how
frightening he is when he does not give
a damn for a short instant he became the
inexorable beast that the avengers had
dreaded all along of course the big
green creature was sooner or later
whacked out and it was quite an awesome
feeling on stark's part
hulk continued to play a lead role part
in the outcome war of avengers age of
ultron known as the battle of sokovia
ultron's mind was connected to thousands
of drones which the hulk managed to chop
up like butter he poked pushed and
tossed them in massive numbers and many
of them even fled from him in sheer
terror of being squished but his
greatest moment came during a brief
interaction with ultron's main body the
robotic antagonist had just been slammed
by iron man thor and vision's collective
strength and was trying to clarify his
behavior hulk nevertheless thumped him
much further into the distance as he was
about to
thank heavens the mcu presented us with
more than one thor vs hulk confrontation
the second encounter took place in thor
ragnarok and it was another hotly
anticipated bloodsport contest between
hulk and thor nevertheless it's not as
balanced as the helicarrier struggle
between the two most powerful and
capable avengers since thor does not
have his mjolnir in the tussle but he
still appeared to have done commendably
against hulk hulk was never one to let
his asgardian club bait off the hook and
this is particularly true in front of
the green giants enraptured enthusiasts
the two of their largest and wittiest
battles so far with each containing some
sturdy knocks and hulk in specific
displaying more deviousness than usual
the hulk wins the battle nevertheless
forecasts and fan speculations recommend
that thor would have managed to win if
the grand master had not swindled
irrespective this was another
accomplishment and confidence boost for
the hulk who is the unchallenged sikar
champion
sir tur's ruination of asgard and thor
ragnarok was said to be a sorrowful and
intense scenario after all it was thor's
place of residence which he had to
voluntarily forfeit so that he or rather
surtur could destroy gila then there was
a dumb hulk who had to have a pissing
contest with searcher to see who the
larger threat was what best
distinguishes the hulk as a superhero is
the way he viciously attacks surtur
without incitement and with complete
impunity his rationale or lack of it is
also simple and clear look at the big
creature attack the big creature it's a
great pity thor and valkyrie clipped the
battle short before he realized who had
won
that's it for today what's your favorite
hulk moment did we leave out another
smasher let us know in the comments down
below be sure to leave us a like if you
enjoyed the video and subscribe for more
content on the biggest upcoming
blockbusters until next time
[Music]
you